in the last video we figured out how
much work or how much energy we have to
put into a particle to move it within a
constant electric field let's see if we
can do the same thing now with a with a
variable electric field and actually
then we can figure out the electric
potential of one position relative to
another so let's say we have a point
charge right it doesn't have to be a
point charge but you know let's just say
that there's some field being generated
by this charge that is a positive I
don't know let's say it's a positive Q
one coulombs and if we wanted to draw a
few lines and of course this is
different then then the example with the
infinite uniformly charged plate because
this will have a variable electric field
right what does the electric field of
this charge the electric field is going
to look like this essentially the amount
of force it'll exert on any particle and
it's always going to be pointed outwards
because we assume that the test particle
in question is always a positive charge
so positive charge will be repelled from
this positive charge electric field is
Coulomb's constant times this charge Q 1
over the distance that we are from this
charge right so if I were to draw this
electric field close up it's pretty
strong close up it's pretty strong and
then as we get further it gets weak and
weaker a little bit it's always radially
outward from the charge this is a bit
review for you all right and these are
just filled this is this is a would you
call it a vector field that I'm drawing
where I'm just randomly picking points
and showing the vector of the field at
that point that it's pointed outward and
at any given radius away from the circle
these vectors should be the same
magnitude I know mine aren't exactly but
hopefully the same at the point right
and the the magnitude these vectors
decrease with the square of the distance
right so that's what the field is going
to look like if I were to draw a bunch
of vector field lines and that makes
sense just as a review right because we
know the force if we had another test
charge Q 2 we know that the force on
that test charge is just Q 2 times this
and that's just
Coulomb's law right that the force on
some other particle q2 is equal to the
electric field times q2 which is equal
to not Q squared Q 2 which is equal to K
q1 q2 over R squared right this is just
Coulomb's law and actually this comes
from Coulomb's law so let's let's since
we know that let's let's take some other
positive charge particle out here and
let's call that q2 and not a big Q I'll
do a small I'll write it up here since I
already messed up down there the q2 and
let's say this is a positive charge so
it is going to be repelled repelled from
this from from q1 and let's say how
let's figure out how much work does it
take to push in this particle to certain
distance right because the field is
pushing it outward it takes work to push
it inward so let's say we want to push
it in and let's say it's at 10 meters
let's say that this distance right here
let me draw a radial radial line let's
say that this distance right here let's
say that that distance is I don't know
10 meters and I want to push this
particle in 5 meters so it eventually
gets right here right this is where I'm
eventually going to get it so then it's
going to be 5 meters away so how much
work does it take to move to move it
five meters towards this charge well the
way you think about it is the the field
keeps changing right but we can assume
over a very very very very infinitely
small distance and let's call that
infinitely small distance dr right
change in radius and as you can see
we're about to embark on some integral
and differential calculus if you don't
understand what any of this is you might
want to review or learn the calculus in
the calculus playlist but how much work
does it require to move this particle a
very very small distance well let's just
assume over this very very very small
distance that the electric field is
roughly constant and so
we can say that the very very small
amount of work to move over that very
very small distance is equal to
Coulomb's constant q1 q2 over R squared
times D R now before we move on let's
think about something for a second
this is Coulomb's law tells us that this
is the outward force that this charge is
exerting on this particle or that the
field is exerting on this particle the
force that we have to apply to move the
particle from here to here has to be an
inward force has to be in the exact
opposite direction right so it has to be
a negative and why is that because we
have to completely offset the force of
the field and you know maybe that if the
particle is already moving a little bit
then our force will will keep it from
decelerating from the field and if it
wasn't already moving we would have to
nudge it just the infinitely small
amount just to get it moving and then
our force would completely offset the
force of the field and the particle
would neither accelerate or decelerate
so this is the amount of work and I just
want to explain that we want to put that
negative sign there because we're going
in an opposite direction of the field so
how do we figure out the total amount of
work right we figured out the amount of
work to get it from here to here and I
even drew it much bigger than it would
be you know these DRS this is an
infinitely small change in radius if we
want to figure out the total work then
we keep adding them up we say okay
what's the work to go from here to here
then the work to go from there to there
then the work to go from there to there
all the way until we get to this five
meters away from from this charge and
what we do and you know we take the sum
of these and then we assume that these
are it's an infinite sum of infinitely
small increments and as you learned that
is nothing but the integral and so that
is the total work the total work is
equal to the integral is going to be a
definite integral because we're starting
at this point we're summing from our
radius is equal to 10 meters that's our
starting point to our rate is equal 5
meters you might not there might be a
little unintuitive that we're starting
at the higher value ending at the lower
value but that's what we're
we're pushing it inwards and then we're
taking the integral of minus K q1 q2
over R squared D are all of these are
constant terms up here right so we could
take them out so this is the same thing
I don't want to run out of space as
minus K q1 q2 times the integral from 10
to 5 of that's well 1 over R squared or
R to the negative 2 d R and that equals
minus K I'm running out of space q1 q2
we take the antiderivative don't have to
worry about plus C because it's a
definite integral R to the negative 2 of
C antiderivative it's minus R to the
negative 1 well that minus R I will just
the minus on the - R will just cancel
with this that becomes a plus R to the
negative 1 and you've evaluated it 5 and
then subtract it evaluated to 10 and
then let me just go up here I know I'm
actually let me erase some of this let
me erase this up here valuable space to
work on so what is so let's see we said
that the work is equal to I'll just
rewrite that we had the minus out here
then we had a - we took the
antiderivative and they cancelled out so
we have K q1 q2 times the antiderivative
evaluated at 5 so 1 over 5 right R to
the negative 1 so 1 over R minus the
antiderivative valued at 10 minus 1 over
10 equal to a 1 over 5 that's the same
thing as 2 over 10 right so we have the
work is equal to K q1 q2 times
to over 10 minus 1 over 10 is 1 over 10
so it equals you go k q-1 q-2 over 10
that's the work to take this the
particle from here to here and so
similarly we could say that the
potential energy of the particle at this
the potential difference of the particle
at this point relative to this point
right that the potential difference here
is this much higher and the new it's
going to be in joules right because
that's the unit of energy or work or
potential well because potential is
energy anyway so the electric potential
difference between this point and this
point at this point it is this value
higher let's do another example and
actually this is that you might just
find this interesting just from
something to think about that the big
difference between I actually let me
just continue this into the next video
because I realize I'm already at 10
minutes I'll see you soon